[音楽]
今から話すことが
私が
ここ最近で体験した
本当にあった出来事です
最近
私の家によく出入りする男がいます
ああっ
[音楽]
彼の名前は
稲垣孝昌
僕たちは彼のことを
縦面と呼んでいますて便座を
いつからでしょうかどこで出会ったかも覚えていません
ですが
気付いた時にはなぜか家に出入りするようになっていました
ん
しばらく彼といて分かったことがあります
あの男は
変だ
ん
あれは
なんだでアニメを見ていた時の話だった
あ僕は困らせていただお菓子を食べたから兄が読み手
した
次は言ってない
ふとをアニメの山に昔を食べようとすると
われんですか
もうないんだけどか
食べたお菓子が全部なくなっていたのでメッツなかったさっきまで
そう
あの男があっ
すべて食べていたのです
は
は来たーー
を受けちゃいましたあ全部やっ入ってるんでございました
ん
これは別の日の話ですが
僕たちがう従業カードのデッキを作っていた時の話です
難波グリフォン
白根陸夫動産部
僕は必要なカードが1枚足りなかったのです
わっ
矢部搾汁財産でもかねぇ
持っている
うわぁあああっっねあっっジャンプが杉山五輪になってる所あるんだよ
フロッグだなぁあっニョッキっ娘
あれがないと買ってるんだん
んだねえともう厳しいかなぁ
その30分後
30分が経ってもなぜかの男は帰ってきませんでしたあれ
は長足ねマジで来ないさもう30分経ってるじゃあばいばーーせ
何やってる
客て見て見てそんな見つかんない
そそんなもんじゃなく何もないでしょ
月経待たせた ok ですっ
パッ
だねぇ
貼っていた
まあ
あの男
カードのことなど忘れてい
歯磨きをしていました
えなに専務らグルっぽカードサーブをくれました
[音楽]
はっはっは
スーッとかはっはー
はっはー
そして
夜私は
この一連の事件をきっかけにはためその男に超不信を抱き
よく一緒に出ていましたティ一緒に寝ることををっブービーはい
[音楽]
そして
次の日の朝のことです
[音楽]
あああ
[笑い]
ん
[音楽]
うん
ああーっ
goo
me
ピュアな
[音楽]
ん